all right you guys aren't gonna believe
this but George W Bush we were just
talking about people dig him impossible
yeah a new gallup poll has come out and
for the first time since 2005 more
Americans have a favorable view of gwb
than an unfavorable view forty-nine
percent have a positive opinion of them
and forty-six percent have a negative
opinion of him this just because of
scandal Palooza that like everyone's
like feeling a little tired of Obama for
the first time so maybe Oh were kind of
missing George W Bush a little bit debut
brink um you know when you break up with
a girl years go by and then you start to
remember them fondly remember the time
they keyed your car or they or they
started checking all of your voicemail
or invaded the wrong country exactly
having some dress in relationships and I
think that's what's happening here
people are starting to remember like the
good things you know the goofy things
about george w bush the fact that he
could like go out and throw out a first
pitch and it would be a strike like
obama is not good at that kind of stuff
well we think fondly you know bush could
bowl and that you know and you gave us
some great moments the whole fool me
once sad i don't know just that don't
just don't fool me and yeah yeah yeah i
think people like that kind of stuff we
need another goofy president what do you
think I want to see these polls I would
really love to see these polls are they
saying they have fond memories because
he's not an office anymore well that's
why I contest of these polls right I
don't know that they look back on the
presidency any better but Ali this does
sort of happen like people always hate
the president when their president
they're always embroiled in scandals and
whatever but then they get out and
people are like oh I he was kind of he's
on his ranch and he's not bothering
anybody yeah i mean i agree with david's
analogy you know i have some douchey
ex-boyfriends then I'm like yeah he
cheated on me but I boys will be boys
right he just got
like ah presents we presidents it
happens yeah if this was because your
act as a part of you that's like look
I'm not with that president anymore so
sure he's okay yeah I really don't think
people are thinking our member when bush
was president alright man it was so
wonderful to be in the lowest economic
times of our lives all rats why couldn't
be back that no no one's thinking they
want to be back there in that point true
i I do kind of think though this has a
little bit to do with that Bush never I
can't believe I'm gonna defend your
jugular and I can and then the comment
section you guys know nuts if you want
um that partly it's because we don't
have any video of him like outright
consistently contradicting himself you
know even forget the Iraq war there was
not a lot of video of him contradicting
himself you know but Obama now like
everything that he said during the
campaign now they're showing that like
you know this NSA thing is the perfect
example like everything that they're
doing is exactly the reverse so as part
of this just because of media and
YouTube and video and Twitter that like
now we can like call them out in a way
that we couldn't before I think most
people are stupid that live in this
country I think that's really the ones
watching except that's why Barry we have
a smart but but honestly i-i didn't vote
for bush that's it I don't know I have
yeah so you can't take credit nor fault
at this poll I'm not exactly sure why
people are remembering him fondly it's a
it's a it's a bit confusing thing I mean
he's got the the for one of the most
illiterate presidents he's got this
library yeah yeah well everyone gets the
library you don't have to be literate to
get the lab but I'm saying he's got this
library which is he should have like
there may be a circus or a or a carnival
named after him instead of a lot of
frozen yogurt stand yeah that doors
dummy most presidential froyo yeah I I
really do think it is because everything
is just piled on Obama at once yeah and
there's a ticking clock now okay now
it's your second term right now you
gotta get done what you said you were
gonna get done and he just keeps getting
cock-blocked by all these diff
things that are just popping up the
drones and the IRS and the the AP and I
mean everything at once so yeah then all
of a sudden was like let's take a poll
now and see this miss bush well sure
you'll be like well gee Bush never had
drones I liked him right no you didn't
yeah even if you don't people that liked
Bush did not like bush yeah I think you
guys are both hitting on this but you
also think it's partly just because of
our general short attention span that we
all now have like nobody remembers
anything anymore and the news cycle is
so quick and because of Twitter
everything is so quick that you just
forget things that you knew to be facts
everyone's one and nothing is tangible
anymore really because before I remember
like we would have a newspaper we'd have
a newspaper in our house and you can go
and you could read an article if I see
something online I want to find it again
it's either been like you know swapped
out for whatever's new you know you go
to like the Yahoo front baby but you
know whatever it's like where's that
thing I read it's like new information
all the time well that's that was ten
seconds ago yeah it's sort of like the
BuzzFeed ification of America like we
don't even read articles we read
pictures with like a little caption in
the form of an article right right
everything in our in our media is us
week lead yeah we're we're just passing
through it it's just like looking at the
pictures of Kim Kardashian's pregnant
yeah I have a complete ban on kardashian
show don't tweet a batter don't talk to
it okay thank you for letting me know
can we retract that anti Kardashian
completely auntie Cardassia
you